>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Carson Block: Right?
All right.
Thanks so much.
Welcome. Good afternoon.
I hope everyone had a great lunch.
And, you know, it's so bright
up here and so dark out there,
if you fell asleep
we wouldn't know it.
But we're going to do our
best to make sure that nobody
in here falls asleep
because this is going
to be an excellent conversation.
My name is Carson Block.
I'm a Library Technology Consultant
on this Tech Trends Panel.
>> John Resig: I'm John Resig.
I work at Khan Academy but
in my spare time I do a lot
of work with libraries.
I'm a developer, my background.
>> Alison Macrina: And
my name is Alison Macrina
and I run the Library
Freedom Project
which is a privacy
activism organization
for libraries and their communities.
And I also work with the Tor Project
who builds privacy and
anonymity software.
>> Carson Block: Outstanding.
We've got a great set of panelists.
We --
>> Alison Macrina:
Shoutout to Jaimee.
>> Carson Block: -- also
are missing somebody, yes.
Jaimee Allay [assumed spelling]
was not able to make it.
She was ill and couldn't
make this session.
So we miss her greatly but we
believe she's on the Twitter
and tweeting things
and including a link
to a resource sheet
after this session.
So please look at that as we go.
Thinking about technology,
we're going to have a very
fast-paced conversation
up here even though we
only have 45 minutes.
We decided we wanted
to cover everything.
Is that okay?
Everyone like everything
about technology?
Great. Okay.
So it's going to go kind of fast.
One thing to remember though
is even as we talk about things
that are granular down in
the field, tech changes --
we have to view them whether
they're a fad or a trend, right?
That's something that we're
always trying to sort out.
One of the things that Jaimee brings
to the panel that I want to talk
about is the discipline of strategic
foresight, and that's the idea
of looking at how many
factors kind of join together
to really help us make
some predictions
or make some good choices
as we go forward.
So we don't look at
technology in a silo,
but we think about all these
things together and think
about what might result including
social, technological, economic,
environmental, and political.
That's an acronym called
STEEP that's very handy
when you're thinking
about the big picture.
The other thing to remember is
there's lots of churn and --
within the technology community.
And one of the bad things in
public libraries specifically --
not everywhere and certainly
not at this conference --
but in public libraries a lot of
times we look at that churn in tech
and we think, oh, gosh we're
losing something as things change.
The rest of the world actually
sees that churn and they go, ah,
we now have new opportunities.
So that's why we want to encourage
you to do, is when you see churn
and things changing that also means
that you've got a brand
new opportunity to pursue.
We have two themes today, and
we will have time for questions
and interaction at the end.
One is around data.
We all love data, right?
Data's big.
It is huge.
Data is important and data's scary.
Also looking at cultural
institution, heritage institutions
in particular, and some of the
tech trends affecting that.
So we're going to start
right away with data.
And as we all know -- we've worked
in institutions that
are data creators.
We've been creating data probably
our entire careers, right?
Well, now, everyone is creating
data in our world, right?
If you have a device on your
wrist to measure your biometrics,
your movements around the
world, that's one sort of thing.
There's that concept
of the quantified self.
But we also have the
so-called Internet of Things
which are the little -- lots of
little things in our environment,
some of those with
sensors collecting lots
of data and creating data pods.
This is happening more
and more and more.
And this is affecting
us because within a lot
of this data collection we have
an expectation of two things
that are kind of in conflict
that we're going to discuss.
What is an expectation of
privacy, right, about our data?
And having it not be exposed
or available to other folks.
The other is an expectation of high
service that comes from analyzing
that data and understanding
patterns, for instance,
in our lives -- where
we're going and at a lot
of degrees what we're doing.
That kind of frames part
of the nuance of the issue.
You're going to dive into that
because we have both
things happening --
expectation of privacy and an
expectation of higher levels
of service using data
to serve customers.
So let's talk a little bit
more about data mining, John.
>> John Resig: Yeah.
So, I mean, one of the
area that I, in general,
that I'm really interested in is
ways in which we can use computers
to automatically analyze large
amounts of data, the sort of things
that would be very, very challenging
to do for us mere mortals, I guess.
But the -- there are a lot of
things that I think are interesting
because like I personally,
I do a lot of work
with different machine-learning
algorithms is finding ways --
you know, ways in which these
computers can make determinations
about things that, in aggregate,
that would be, you know,
looking at hundreds of thousands, if
not millions, of records of things
that would take a human an
exceedingly long amount of time.
And I think the point you were
touching on before about sort
of tech trends and -- another
thing I would put in there would be
like sort of a pragmatism and --
because one of the things
that's tricky is that at least
when you're using things like
machine learning algorithms,
those things are extremely
technically complex.
You usually have to have
someone with at least a degree
in computer science who's capable
of working on these sort of things,
and it's not the sort of thing that
you can usually just kind of drop in
and things magically get sorted out.
It requires a lot of, you know,
very technical staff
and a lot of training.
And one of the things that
I think is interesting is --
one of the problems is actually
really hard to determine is
when do you need a magical computer
system to solve all your problems?
When do you just need one single
domain expert to kind of go in
and just figure things out?
And then like when do you
need maybe just like a lot
of crowdsourcing to happen?
And like these are all
like different steps.
And it's sometimes it's very hard as
an organization to kind of say, oh,
you know -- because I feel like
people like to make the fast leap
to the most technologically
cool thing they can.
So it's like, oh, we can just
use this amazing algorithm
and everything will be amazing.
But then there's like, well,
what if we just hire, you know,
this person over there
and they will just do it
and because they know this
stuff really well, and they --
we don't need them like to develop
a brand new algorithm to do it.
So, yeah, I guess this is one thing.
Like I'm excited about but
I'm willing to hedge my bets
and I'm willing to say
that, you know, like it's --
we need to consider this
very, very carefully.
>> Carson Block: Absolutely.
It's like the right tool for the
right job, and I think raising
that question is really important.
And sometimes raising the
question of should we do it at all.
>> Alison Macrina: I was
just about to ask that.
I mean, with a lot of these -- you
just said something about, you know,
like it's sort of this
like exciting new frontier.
And I think when we are
presented with those things,
especially in libraries, we want to
provide a benefit to our patrons.
And maybe sometimes we don't
always consider what the possible
implications for exploitation
would be.
You know, with data in that size, I
think about a few different things.
The first thing is who owns it?
Because most of the time when we're
talking about like big datasets
like that, we're talking
about negotiating
with giant private companies,
sometimes the most
powerful in the world.
Now, is that who we want, especially
as public servants, you know?
Is that good stewardship of data?
I think that it's not.
At the same time who else is
going to be able to manage it?
Who else can provide us with
that level of information?
I also think about, you know,
are we considering what kind
of identifiable information is
in that data and how we got it
and how it's being shared.
Who has access to it?
How it's stored.
Is it secure?
Because when you have information
at that level and you connect it
to a network, the avenues for
exploitation are suddenly massive.
It's not just people, you know,
possibly hacking it, but, you know,
law enforcement requests.
If you have information,
then it can be subpoenaed.
I've seen some really
incredible projects
with open data, for
example, city data.
Like I live in Massachusetts and the
Massachusetts ACLU has been working
on this project called
Technology for Justice.
A really amazing thing where
they've taken open city data
and they're mapping policing in
Boston and showing how, you know,
not surprising to activists, how it
maps along racially divided lines
and it also maps along access
to social services and things
like even train routes
and stuff like that.
And you begin to see
like white neighborhoods
where they don't even
let people of color
in because the stop ratio
is just right outside.
That kind of stuff is incredible.
But what are we getting within that?
Are we getting the names and
addresses of all those people
of color who have been
stopped by police?
Is that information that --
is it in the public benefit?
So I want to make sure that
we're asking all these questions
as we're going into this
new exciting frontier.
>> Carson Block: And how many people
are actually asking those questions
as we're --
>> Alison Macrina: Not that many.
>> Carson Block: -- going
forward [laughter], right?
And I think that's
kind of an admin --
something that we would like to
keep you with in terms of this idea
that it's exciting and it's bad.
>> Alison Macrina: Mm-hmm.
>> Carson Block: It's actually up
to us to ask these questions and --
>> Alison Macrina: Totally.
>> Carson Block: -- actually
to understand that chain
that all these things operate
in because you were just talking
about many different pieces of
the technical infrastructure,
the physical, the digital,
and how many --
so to all the people
it's just a cloud.
>> Alison Macrina:
Yeah, right [laughter].
There's -- I love the
cloud as like one
of the most effective
marketing gimmicks that exists
because there is no cloud, right?
There's no -- it's not like a
beautiful like floating zeros
and ones up in the sky, you know?
I mean it's a server,
it's a physical server
that lives somewhere.
You know, you have to start
thinking about the cloud
as an actual physical place.
It's a server somewhere that
somebody maintains, you know.
And, you know, the cloud I think
there's too much trust that we put
in these ideas of the
cloud, you know.
And I think we need
to be more skeptical.
>> Carson Block: Indeed.
What do you think as
well in terms of --
what are practical ways that folks
can go out of this room and go,
I think I want to check
on dot, dot, dot, dot?
Because I hope you're
all think that right now.
>> John Resig: Yeah.
I mean, yeah, I guess, yeah, one
of the tricky things that you kind
of like need to ask the
question like who is benefitting
from access to this information?
And -- yeah, I guess when
I think about like --
when I think of like a successful
project that uses lots of data
in aggregate versus one
that's a lot more borderline,
and usually in every case of that --
I can think of one
that's successful, it's --
well, there's a phrase
in comedy, what --
are you punching up or
are you punching down?
>> Alison Macrina: Right, totally.
>> John Resig: Yeah, like are you --
you know, are you impacting
people who, you know,
are running the government, or
the police, or things, you know,
the institutions that were,
you know, surrounding us?
Or are we affecting people
who we should not yet --
like there's no reasons
to be, you know,
putting their addresses
online or something like that.
>> Alison Macrina: Right.
Public interest.
>> John Resig: Yes.
>> Alison Macrina: Yeah.
>> John Resig: Absolutely.
So, yeah. I feel like that is --
that's a really big aspect of it.
And I think being very deliberate
in realizing who's
going to be impacted.
>> Alison Macrina: And I think
we care about these things,
but we don't even necessarily
know the right questions to ask.
I mean, a lot of this is
above our technical paygrade.
Many of us working in
libraries, even those of us
who are fairly technical,
like there's no possible way.
The whole thing is too
big to know, you know.
So even being able to go in and
say, look, I want to make sure
that we do the most ethical
things that we can here.
How do you start that?
>> John Resig: Mm-hmm.
>> Carson Block: How
do you start it?
>> Alison Macrina:
Oh, man [laughter].
Well, I mean --
>> Carson Block: Because,
because you're very good
at starting that conversation.
>> Alison Macrina: Well, thank you.
I mean, a few things that I
mentioned already, you know,
like who -- you know, think about
data as like having, you know,
a physical form effectively.
I think that is very
helpful to think about it
like the cloud is this like
nebulous sort of thing.
Like it actually has
a server location
so who owns that server, you know?
And what are they doing with it?
What's their interest in it?
You know, I think about the biggest
cloud provider would probably be
Google because of just the number,
the sheer number of services
that we rely on from
Google all the time.
And Google is the -- one of the
world's most powerful companies.
They are an advertising company.
They collect that information
to generate advertising
revenue from it, you know?
I know, shocker.
>> Carson Block: No.
>> Alison Macrina: Right.
>> Carson Block: It is a shocker.
>> Alison Macrina:
Ninety-something percent
of Google's revenue is from ads.
>> Carson Block: But a lot of
people don't think about that.
>> Alison Macrina: They
don't think about it, right.
And they don't think about
Google having actual servers
where Google's engineers
have actual access to it,
or Google has actual --
has a negotiation with it.
Google does a great job at
server security, you know.
That is one thing that
they've really prioritized,
especially after Snowden.
So that's the second thing,
like not just who owns it
and who accesses it, but how is it
stored, because that's, you know,
that physical server somebody
could exploit it, and then they --
you have a whole other
set of problems.
And then it's like, then within
the dataset itself, you know,
how are you dealing with
personally identifying information?
What constitutes personally
identifying information?
Is there such a thing as
anonymized data in aggregate?
No, there is not it
turns out [laughter].
It takes --
>> Carson Block: The
devil is in the details.
>> Alison Macrina: -- three data
points to identify any human.
We're all special snowflakes.
So, you know, these
are -- those are some
of the first questions I would ask.
>> Carson Block: Very good.
>> Alison Macrina: I don't know.
What other questions?
>> John Resig: Yeah.
I mean there are a couple points
about -- are really fantastic.
And it's like, yeah, when you're
using a service for free you have
to ask yourself, well,
who is actually --
like where's the money
coming -- yeah.
>> Alison Macrina:
Versus -- right, totally.
>> John Resig: Right.
So if you're using -- an example
I'll bring up here because --
I really like Flickr, for example.
And I know a lot of institutions
have used that to put --
upload the images to Flickr,
provide nice little
annotations, community engagement.
But like that's a great
example where if, you know,
using it for free you're like, well,
at the end of the day,
who's the product?
>> Alison Macrina: You.
>> John Resig: Yeah,
exactly [laughter].
The content you're putting
up there is the product.
>> Alison Macrina: Right.
>> John Resig: And it's
interesting because like, you know,
just the other day like Yahoo,
like very quietly announced
that Flickr is now a legacy service.
Read into that what you will, but
the way I would read into it is
like I'm getting my stuff
off of there in [laughter] --
but the thing is like this --
so this is another
issue is like I would --
I'm never going to put any
data on a service for free,
or actually for pay
for that matter --
>> Alison Macrina: Right.
>> John Resig: -- that I
don't have a back-up for.
>> Alison Macrina: sure.
But this is the great
point that actually
that Internet Archive has been
doing a project around, you know,
a perpetual cloud storage.
And that was exactly the
angle that they took.
They were like, think of all
these services that you relied
on that now no longer exist
and, ergo, all of your pictures
and all of your memories.
And so, yeah, not just who owns it
but what happens when they fail?
There's the legacy part of it, you
know, maybe it just disappears.
And then the other part of
it is that data is an asset.
If a company goes bankrupt
your data can get sold
when they get bought out, you know.
So these are all different things.
It's like thinking about
this ownership thing.
What happens then, you know, when
that like little startup is gone
or bought by somebody bigger?
>> John Resig: Mm-hmm.
Yeah. I guess -- I think one
of the things that's extremely
challenging here though is
that the nice part about free
service is that they're free.
And that when you have not --
when you don't have an
in-house technical staff
and when you don't have the
ability to run your own servers
and do all these sort of
things, free sounds really nice.
And so this is the thing.
I feel like I don't have a good
answer for because it's like well,
okay, you just stop, don't
rely upon this free thing.
But the things is that on the other
side is like well, you kind of have
to have like all these other things.
>> Alison Macrina: But there are
different kinds of free, right?
I think it's totally legit, like
we have to think about, you know,
what kind of -- what kind of
like exchange is happening
when we get something for free?
Is it -- it's our data, you
know, that we're volunteering.
I work a lot with free and
open source software and to me
that is a good -- it's
not an ideal solution,
but at least the reason why
you get the thing for free is
that it is a community effort,
that all these different people all
over the world are working
on it, usually as volunteers,
and that is a thing that I like
to put my trust in a little more
than like private company who maybe
makes something more sophisticated
and nicer.
You know, I think about,
you know, the difference
between like Google Maps and
OpenStreetMaps, for example.
OpenStreetMaps is a free
and open source project
that doesn't work as well.
Google works really well because
they got the little cars that drive
around and take pictures, and
they're monitoring you when you're
in traffic and all this stuff.
But I think the first thing is
people have to know, you know,
what kind of exchange you're making.
>> Carson Block: But I think
I have a magic bullet answer
that no one's going to believe.
>> Alison Macrina: Go on.
>> Carson Block: We need to invest
more in our technology people
in our cultural heritage
institutions and our libraries.
Constantly what I've
been seeing again is,
especially on the leadership level,
they'll confuse free
with free, right?'
>> Alison Macrina: Mm-hmm.
>> Carson Block: So a free
open source software is free
as in freedom for you to pick up
the ball and to do something with it
and it's [inaudible] community.
>> Alison Macrina: It
takes time and -- mm-hmm.
>> Carson Block: And that
investment actually has been lower.
I would say that because of the
tipping point that we're at with --
and we're just -- the tip
of the iceberg is what we're
talking about in this issues.
Because of that we need
more knowledgeable workers
on the IT side, on
the technology side,
that understand how the technology
impacts not just our services
that we're giving people,
not just what they get,
but also how we're doing it.
Are we adhering to our own culture
of privacy or confidentiality?
Are we doing the details
and due diligence in that?
Right now we're not investing in
that in any way, shape, or form.
And also I don't think we're
cultivating the right sort
of tech leaders either.
We've got lots of siloed folks who
are passionate and leading the ways
in these little areas,
but not joined enough.
And we also have some people that
are better at marketing themselves
in terms of being wow, gee
whiz, instead of really looking
at the people we serve, the
ideals that we're trying to serve
in our communities in
carrying those forward.
So I'll get off my soapbox on that.
But that's a --
>> Alison Macrina: That's a
very good soapbox [laughter].
Hire them and pay them a lot
more than what we're paying them.
>> Carson Block: Yes, yes.
>> Alison Macrina: That is dreadful.
>> Do your best, everybody.
>> Alison Macrina: Really.
We should be embarrassed by that.
>> Carson Block: Yeah, yeah.
That's what I'm saying [laughter].
Very nice [laughter].
But don't feel bad, okay
because we've all --
we know what the reality is.
Every -- we do up here.
Let's move into some specific
things about cultural heritage data.
We've got lots of content.
We have lots of awesome,
awesome content.
I can't believe some of
the great programs here.
I could not decide what to go to
next because of the awesome content.
We also have this tension between
the aggregation and the hooks
into it so that we can have
great content in one pot
and share it in so many places.
And then the hyper local
stuff because as we know,
some of this content
that we're curating
and making available is the
most important back home, right?
So that's an interesting,
that's an interesting tension.
And we don't want to leave it in a
silo, but it's really used there.
The other thing that occurs to
me in terms of our uniqueness is
that usually technology, we
use technology, hopefully,
to get an economy of scale.
That doesn't happen
very often in libraries
because of the special
snowflake problem.
Great libraries are hyper local
so that's our initial orientation.
So it's very hard to get
technology that scales nationally
and internationally in the same way.
That's really a problem of
cultural heritage institutions.
Not a problem, but it's a challenge
because even our processing
is really based
on material type, right?
I had one job where I was supposed
to go in and find more efficiencies
between the different types
of material type processing,
and not only could I not find
cross efficiencies that would work,
I couldn't find any evidence that
anyone else has found that either.
When you look at all the standards,
they're highly specialized
to their material type, right?
So a document, for instant, has
a different set of standards,
requirements, and nuance
than a photograph, right,
in terms of metadata,
descriptive, sharing it out.
Many things that everyone
here knows about.
There's also something really
interesting that doesn't get talked
about nearly enough,
and that's rights.
Who owns the stuff?
Alison.
>> Alison Macrina: Well,
it's certainly not us,
and it should be [laughter].
I mean, yeah, I mean what's
a longer answer than not us?
Yeah. I --
>> Carson Block: Honest
is good [laughter].
>> Alison Macrina: Yeah.
That's like an exchange that we've
been making over and over again.
Like thinking again about, you know,
our inability to provide our own
services or like create the kind
of tools that we need to
engage our patrons, you know,
with digital collections and stuff.
You know we've moved to
entirely third-party models
and we've seen some of
the failures of this.
I mean, the Adobe thing was a
scandal, as it should have been.
That is just one of
these ways that --
and the Adobe thing was
a big problem, obviously,
because of the privacy breech.
But it had been a problem
before that, I mean,
because DRM is antithetical
to library values.
The whole way that we've moved away
from an ownership model
into a licensing model.
I mean, we should have never
said yes to that, and we did.
And I understand like
what we were thinking,
but now it's very difficult to get
the toothpaste back in the tube.
From a rights based standpoint,
you know, again thinking about,
you know, who stores and
owns data and how that --
what that means for access.
If I am law enforcement and
I want to send, for example,
a national security letter which
is a government subpoena that comes
with an attached gag order
that says like you have to hand
over information about your patrons
or your customers or whomever,
and you can't tell
anyone that you've got it.
Libraries in 2005 received
one of these.
We don't have very good data
about how many other
libraries may have gotten them
because they have gag
orders attached to them.
It's a very scary thing for
libraries to have to contend
with this in a post-911 world.
Even scarier is that if we rely
on all these third party vendors,
we will never see that notice.
We won't even be --
>> Carson Block: Right.
>> Alison Macrina: -- able to
talk to our attorneys or the ACLU
or whomever because it
goes directly to Adobe
or OverDrive or Elsevier
or whatever.
And so we've in some ways, you know,
our charge of like
protecting privacy
and protecting intellectual
freedom and all the amazing things
that we've done in the
interest of that where we're
like we purge records
and we, you know,
we fight back against
unlawful information requests.
It's been taken out of our hands.
And that it is a --
that's a scary new world.
>> Carson Block: It especially is
because I know that in the times
when I was in -- working,
when I actually had
gainful employment working
in a library, I was
in a city library.
I would get a call from --
usually it would be a casual call
from the police department,
a department that's part
of our stable, right?
We are colleagues within
the organization.
It would be a casual call saying,
so, we want to know if so and so was
at the library at a certain time.
>> Alison Macrina: Yeah.
>> Carson Block: And
I would say, so,
you know that legally I cannot
give you that information.
>> Alison Macrina: They
always do it so casually, too.
They're like --
>> Carson Block: Yeah.
>> Alison Macrina: -- we're friends.
We're all in the same community.
Don't worry about the
warrant provision.
Like, you know, we're buddies.
>> Carson Block: And at least at
that level they were asking, right?
>> Alison Macrina: Yeah.
>> Carson Block: They
would ask for that.
And actually my -- like
with law enforcement,
we always had great conversations
because what I would say is,
you know, I can't give you
anything without a subpoena.
However, we don't like
people breaking the law.
So let's have a conversation
about this.
What is actually prosecutable
evidence in this case?
>> Alison Macrina: Yeah, yeah.
>> Carson Block: And a lot of
times the officers I would talk to,
they would say, well, you know,
if we can see somebody doing
something that's better
than anything.
That's like, why don't you
just visit the library then
if you think someone's
breaking the law.
We'd love to see you.
And we don't want lawbreaking
to happen within our building.
We don't want people
to get hurt, you know.
So that's a different sort
of conversation than, hey,
we just got the honeypot
from Google.
>> Alison Macrina: Right, yeah.
>> Carson Block: We don't even
need to talk to you about this.
>> Alison Macrina: Don't even
need to talk to you, yeah.
Totally. Yeah.
>> John Resig: Yeah.
There's also the -- another tricky
issue in here which is the rights
over the material itself by the
people who originally created it,
or were involved in its creation.
Like there was this blockbuster I
just read recently about a library
that had digitized a lot of
really like old zines and stuff.
So from pre-Internet era.
>> Carson Block: How nice.
>> John Resig: And so when they
were created there was never an
expectation that they
would be digitized
and distributed all over the world.
You know, that they
were inherently --
there were going to be just
these couple dozen copies
and they would go to friends.
And so the problem then
becomes is that some
of these contained material that
mentioned very specific people,
and if they were connected
back to those people
who were still very much
alive, that it would --
you know, it harmed their lives.
>> Carson Block: Sure, yeah.
>> John Resig: So like, so this kind
of ties into the general like right
to be forgotten where like do
those people have the right --
then request through the library
or whatever institution
had digitized it,
that this material be
redacted or removed.
And this is something that I'm still
mentally trying to grapple with.
I'm not sure I completely
understand it or can appreciate it.
And I think one of the things
that's challenging though --
but one of the points about this
I think I did understand was
that libraries have that need
to have very clear policies
around this, about like if you --
if there is material that we have
digitized and have made accessible,
that does involve you,
do you have the ability
to request that they be removed?
>> Alison Macrina: Yeah.
>> John Resig: And if so, what is
the ways in which that can happen?
>> Alison Macrina: It
goes back to the point
that you were making
earlier about like, you know,
what the power differential
there is, you know.
Because I believe very strongly in
transparency for powerful people
and entities like governments
and corporations.
But privacy for individuals and the
right to be forgotten is so tricky
because you don't want to open
up the opportunity for, you know,
powerful entities to be able to say,
well now I want to
censor this stuff.
But also some rights
are in conflict.
I see the right to be
forgotten is a kind of extension
of the Fifth Amendment
because if, you know,
I want to remove information about
myself because, you know, for --
I might not want to
solve, incriminate,
or just because that should
belong to me in some way.
But it's not an easy
thing to figure out.
And then at an institutional
level, how do you,
like, write a policy for that?
You know, how do you even --
>> Carson Block: How
do you understand it?
>> Alison Macrina: Yeah.
>> Carson Block: Right?
>> Alison Macrina: Totally.
>> Carson Block: And
on the other side
of things we've got this
content that is great
for mixing and mashing up.
And I just experienced that.
It was so cool.
I'm working with Boulder Public
Library and we had a focus group
for part of the Carnegie
Library for Local History.
And this guy calls me up later.
He says, "I want you to see
this website I created called
hereminus100, so it's -- what he
did is he took all these different
mashups of vintage
historical photographs.
For instance, he had
a lot of mashups,
but this one was really
kind of funny.
He had a slider where he took
his own modern photograph
from the same vantage point
and it was so incredibly cool.
He didn't ask anybody
if this was okay.
He just said, "Ah,
what do you think?
Do you think they'll get mad?"
That was his question to me.
He goes, "Do you think
they'll get mad?"
And I said, "Well, let's
look at the rights --
>> Alison Macrina: Yeah.
>> -- "on the photograph number
one, because that's the bottom line.
Mad's really got nothing
to do with it."
>> Alison Macrina: Right.
>> Carson Block: "Let's see if
you have the ability to use this.
And I think it's awesome" --
>> Alison Macrina:
Mm-hmm [laughter].
>> Carson Block: --
"at the same time."
But I keep thinking
that that's one type.
We're also creating all
sorts of new digital content
that I think will be ported
into all sorts of things
like video game characters or
situations or motifs, for instance.
Are you seeing anything that you
think is awesome when it comes
to the sorts of things
that are being collected
by cultural heritage
institutions now,
and thinking that could
be used as dot, dot, dot?
So do you think that
peaks your interest there?
>> Alison Macrina: Hmm.
That's a good question.
>> Carson Block: Well,
we'll keep looking around --
>> Alison Macrina: Yeah [laughter].
>> Carson Block: --
while we're here.
That was not on the script.
>> Alison Macrina: I
mean it's making me think
about copyright issues
more broadly I think.
And it made my brain go
in a different direction.
And just, you know, like
thinking about not just the way
that our public is consuming
information and creating new things
with it, and the implications of
that for copyright, plus, you know,
new copyright issues, especially
with like trade agreements and all
that sort of stuff that like would
create really draconian new rules
around like DRM and other
licensing and stuff.
And then also thinking
about like again, you know,
in terms of like what the
public is kind of interested in
and what they might want from
us as cultural institutions.
Looking at the popularity
of Sci-Hub and LibGen,
which are basically like, you
know, pirated academic papers
for free online as they
should be, totally free.
It's totally illegal
else we are suing them.
But it's like in the Arron Swartz
like direct action kind of vein
of like let's put this all
online because people need it
and people are benefitting
from it, and they love it.
And everybody who, you know --
I mean, those of us in academic
institutions or anybody who has
to deal with any kind of
like, you know, pay wall
or per use subscription understands
why these things are so popular.
So like what does that mean
for us in terms of, you know,
the rights of the copyright
holder but what we need
to provide as a public service?
I don't really have an answer.
I'm just sort of thinking about it.
>> John Resig: I think one of
the things that's interesting is
that there are two aspects of this.
One is legally who has the right to
do activities with a certain thing?
And that can be usually defined
with the help of a lawyer.
And I will call out the, you know,
the work that a near
public library did.
And they're -- discussion
this afternoon on it as well,
if I remember [inaudible].
This afternoon or next afternoon.
I don't remember.
But -- this afternoon, okay.
And -- but the work that they did
to methodically go through a lot
of their materials and digitize
materials and figure out what was
or was not in the public domain.
And like that work is so, so hard
and so few institutions actually do
that because it is, one,
it's time consuming,
and that time is usually lawyer
time which is very expensive.
And, so, like -- and --
but the thing is, is that a lot
of institutions don't do this
and instead they hedge their bets
with a lot of very vague language
where they say, like, oh, this is
public domain for academic use.
And you're like, what is
that even -- that doesn't --
is not a thing that
exists, all right?
You know, like either it's public
domain or it's not public domain.
But the --
>> Carson Block: Like a license.
>> Alison Macrina:
Yeah [laughter], right.
>> John Resig: So the things
is, is that there is --
but there's a tricky part of
that here, and maybe this is sort
of a thread of what we're going
through here is, you know,
having the right to put something
online is not the same --
like you could be legally
totally in the clear.
However, you have to think
about who's going to get upset.
Who could this impact?
And so like upsetting Elsevier
is a completely different thing
from upsetting, you know,
someone whose personal
information you put on --
>> Alison Macrina: Totally.
>> John Resig: -- because
it was published back
in like 1970 in a zine or something.
Like there's are things that kind
of have to be mentally separating.
You have to think about who, you
know, who is being hurt by this
or could be hurt or could be upset.
Yeah.
>> Carson Block: Absolutely.
Well, we have about
10 more minutes left.
>> Alison Macrina: Oh, wow.
That went by so fast.
>> Carson Block: And doesn't it
go -- it just goes by so quick.
And we know that we
covered a lot of stuff.
We kind of wanted to have a
smorgasbord of different topics
that we thought were interesting
in tech trends in libraries
and cultural heritage institutions.
But we would love this to
have your voice in it, too.
Is there any comments that you have?
Any questions that you have for us?
And I think we've got a roving
microphone around here somewhere.
But we'd love to hear your comments.
We'd especially love to hear
things that you're struggling with.
It's good to hear.
Any questions or comments?
Lunch was good.
Oh, yes. We've got a gentleman here.
Let's see.
I think they're coming over
to you with the microphone.
>> Okay.
>> John Resig: Oh,
down the other side.
>> Carson Block: Oh, here we go.
Take your choice.
You can be stereo [laughter].
Speak in both of them I think.
>> Alison Macrina: Use them both.
>> Okay. Two things I
didn't think I heard.
I'd like to get your opinions on.
One of them is RDF and link data.
And the other's deep learning.
>> Alison Macrina: Wait.
You --
>> Carson Block: I'm sorry.
Could you repeat --
>> Alison Macrina: --
speak into the microphone.
I --
>> Carson Block: Yeah.
Hold on. We'll --
>> Hold it up.
Sorry, sorry.
>> Carson Block: Thank you.
>> So two technologies I
didn't hear about which I'd
like to get your take on -- RDF
and linked data and deep learning.
The relevance of both of
those or not to the library.
>> John Resig: Okay.
Yeah. I guess I have
opinions on these.
So I've been doing work
with RDF and linked data.
So, sort of the promise
of this technology is
that if everyone has their
information in a consistent format,
talked about in the same way,
that when you say this is a thing
called a book and it was written
by a thing called an author,
and that author is described
by these names and et cetera, et
cetera, that you will be able to,
you know, show like for example
all the books that were written
by a particular author
or were published
by a certain publisher
or et cetera, et cetera.
And all of this extends
beyond books.
You can do this for art; you can
do this for all sorts of things.
I feel like the -- one of the
things that's really tricky
with the particular thing,
though, is that it is --
it's extremely idealistic in that --
if you look at the
absolute best case scenario,
where all the data is perfect and
everyone has put a lot of time
and effort into making it perfect,
that best case scenario is amazing.
Like you can do so much stuff and
explore so many relationships.
However, the reality is that
many institutions do not have the
ability, either technical or
logistical, to make it perfect.
And so what you end up having are
a lot of institutions are somewhere
down here who are just trying
to get basic information
into their records, and so that
promise is not fully realized.
So I think this is one thing that
is going to be a major struggle.
Whereas like big institutions
like the British Museum,
like they have a ton of like really
good linked data because that's
because they're the British Museum.
Whereas like a small,
you know, a small library
or something is not going
to have that ability.
They don't have the
staff to make it happen.
So I think that's one
where you kind of --
I feel like you have to
kind of take it with a,
you know, a grain of salt.
Where it's like, yes, in a perfect
world that could be amazing.
But think about your specific
use case and think about, okay,
what are the questions
we're trying to ask?
How can we answer them?
And then, how can we do
that with that sort of --
in that limited little area?
I guess the other question you
had was about deep learning.
So, specifically, deep learning
is a type of machine learning,
and it's been popularized
recently via Google
and other organizations
doing deep learning for --
like detecting objects in images,
using it for like their self-driving
cars, and stuff like that.
And so one of the things --
like I've been experimenting with
different deep learning algorithms
to find and annotate images
to improve their searchability,
for example.
And this is interesting.
One of the tricky things is that you
have to be aware of what you're --
how comfortable you are
with wrong answers, okay?
So like -- because the
thing is that deep learning
like really good algorithms
will be right.
Let's say you have an image
with a -- there's a dog in it.
Most algorithms will say,
in its top five guesses,
it will be right 60%
of the time, okay?
Or like just as an example.
Whereas like that's
like the -- okay --
>> Carson Block: Sixty percent.
No, I was just -- I
was in that top five --
>> John Resig: Yeah, yeah.
So it will be like
cat, chicken, dog.
And it's like, okay, well,
you got it mostly right.
You know, there's a dog
in there [laughter].
And -- but the, but the -- so
the thing is, is that that --
>> Carson Block: I think we
went to a fortune teller.
They had the same success rate.
>> John Resig: So like for example,
I used this for the dataset recently
of artworks created
by artists, okay?
But the problem is, is that you need
a lot of training data to train it
to kind of be like okay, here are
a ton of cats and here are a ton
or dogs or -- but in the case of
paintings, you don't have that.
You know, you only have a
very small subset of data.
And I think the problem
is, is that yeah, it's --
the theoretical future, again,
is going to be very cool.
In the meantime, you have
to be very willing to have
like wrong answers be prevalent.
And you saw this just
recently like --
again, bring up Flickr
again of all things.
Like they did this for their images.
Whenever you upload an image they
automatically annotate it with tags.
And then you start having
really bad things happen
when you have automatic
annotation happen.
Like one of the things was like it
started to annotate people of color
with like monkey and
stuff like that,
which is like terrible, terrible.
And it's like it should
not be happening.
But that's because it -- how
they trained the algorithm was
completely misguided.
>> Alison Macrina: Right.
The engineers were like
our algorithm is neutral.
We showed it only white faces
because that's what
we think of as people.
And then, of course, you have
these outcomes that are awful
and offensive and inaccurate.
And people are like no, but the data
like algorithms are all neutral.
But people are not, you know.
Math might be neutral,
but like people can,
you know -- they screwed up.
>> John Resig: So,
anyway [laughter].
As long as we're saying that I feel
like there's still a lot
of hurdles to overcome.
>> Alison Macrina: Yeah.
>> John Resig: And --
>> Alison Macrina: Well, look at
how fast the Microsoft AI went Nazi.
>> Carson Block: Oh, yeah.
>> Alison Macrina: She
went full Nazi 24 hours --
>> Carson Block: Bam, bam.
>> Alison Macrina: I mean,
if you can't design your bot
to be Fortran-resistant in 2016 --
[ Laughter ]
-- what the hell are you doing?
They were just like repeat after me.
And she did.
I mean, of course, you know.
And so one thing I'm very interested
in is a burgeoning movement
of ethics in AI and machine
learning and bots and all
that fun stuff, you know?
Like how do you train
a machine to be cool?
>> Carson Block: Yeah.
How do we raise our
digital children?
>> Alison Macrina: Yeah,
exactly, exactly, exactly.
>> Carson Block: Yeah, yeah.
And I love the standards
question because standards I think
at best are only referenced
by the world, right?
Like in a closed system
we can maintain them.
And I'm saying this because
I work on a little --
a lot of building project.
And let me tell you something about
how standards and specifications,
which are hard in a building, are
just kind of referenced sometimes
in that old construction process.
So that is a super challenge there,
especially with the churn
in technology, right?
Things are changing all the time.
We're realizing we haven't covered
everything, and how do we cover it?
Do we have any other questions?
Is food digesting well after lunch?
>> John Resig: I know
this is the [inaudible].
>> Alison Macrina: There's one more.
>> Carson Block: Excellent.
Oh, good. Thank you.
Thanks.
>> I would just like to hear more
about what trends you're excited
about or any projects you've
heard that are really interesting.
>> Carson Block: Hmph.
>> Alison Macrina: One trend
that I'm really excited
about is something that like
generally I call secure defaults
which are that we -- the Internet,
generally speaking, is
a very hostile place.
It is not secure or private
by default almost ever.
The whole thing is
written on postcards.
That means, you know, exactly
what you think it means,
that anyone can see the
metadata and the content
of what you're doing
depending on the kind
of connections you're making.
So what's been happening
now is there's a push
to make things secure by default.
And one project that I'm so excited
about, especially the implications
that it has for libraries and
cultural heritage institutions,
is something called Let's Encrypt.
Let's Encrypt is a project with --
it's being worked on by the
Electronic Frontier Foundation.
If you don't know them,
they're sort of like the ACLU
but just for the Internet.
Electronic Frontier
Foundation, Mozilla, Akamai,
a few other really big
Internet Service Institutes,
you know, public and private.
And basically what Let's Encrypt
is doing is making it really easy
for anyone who runs a webserver,
that is to say a website,
to set up strong https encryption on
the whole site by default forever.
So free automated renewals
every year.
This is a really important thing
for libraries especially
given our charge
for stewardship of
our patrons' privacy.
If our library websites
are not encrypted,
if they use just regular
http to connect,
that means that when your patrons
are going on your site and looking
up books about divorce or
diabetes or gender identity
or any other sensitive topics,
that is going out over the wire
up to the rest of the
Internet in plain text.
Anyone can see it.
They can see the originating
location.
They can see that it's
coming from your library.
And if you've got an encrypted
login page, like if you encrypt
where they enter their library
card, that is actually worthless.
And even worse is that
it can create a cookie
that then can be intercepted
by someone, so they can steal
that login information and then also
still see everything that's being
done after the secure login.
So Let's Encrypt is a project
to make it really simple
for all library websites
to use encryption.
I'm really happy that DPLA
has prioritized this actually.
Mark has been working on this.
They're not using Let's
Encrypt but they have --
they're about to like fully
deploy https for their site,
and they ran into some mixed
content issues and other things.
But they ended up fixing it and
it took them just about a week,
I think, to get it all together.
If your library's interested
in Let's Encrypt,
and you don't really
know what you're doing,
you can talk too Library
Freedom Project.
We have a privacy pledge
that we've gotten a bunch
of people to sign onto.
So that's probably
the biggest thing.
And the sort of the most
important and like something
that any library should do.
And I'm encouraged to see
how many have done it so far.
>> John Resig: I think
very tangentially,
one of the technologies
that I'm most excited about,
and I'll second Let's Encrypt.
I've been using it myself
and I think it's fantastic.
>> Alison Macrina: Awesome.
>> John Resig: and it is --
I've been using different
computer vision algorithms,
but there's one particular type
of algorithm which is the kind
that you see in like
Google Image Search or in --
people familiar with TinEye,
where you can like upload an image
and it will find images
that look like that image.
Now I feel like this is a
particular problem that makes
for a fantastic finding aid because
the thing is, is that when it comes
to images if you don't have,
you know, amazing metadata to go
with it, it can be
hard to locate them.
However, if you have -- computers
are really good at, you know,
seeing that these two images are
very, very similar to each other.
So there are different
commercial algorithms out there.
However, there's one open source,
one I've been using just recently
called Pastec, P-A-S-T-E-C.
And it's written by
this French developer.
And I and some other people
in the digital humanities
world have been contributing
to this particular
algorithm because, one,
it's the only open source one
that we know of, and, two,
that it seems to actually
be pretty good.
So, like for example, like I've been
using it for some of my projects
to help scholars locate
our artworks.
But like the Brooklyn Museum,
for example, just last week,
they took this and implemented a
piece of software so that people,
when they're going around the
museum, can photograph artworks
and it will find all the
information about the artwork,
and just by looking at
the photo that they took.
So like it's really
easy to implement.
So this is one thing I feel like
can have an immediate direct impact
on people who are like
trying to find information.
And I think like that's like pretty
much like one of the definitions
of what a library is
and what it provides.
So I'm very excited about that.
>> Carson Block: That's excellent.
We're almost out --
we are over time,
but I'll just mention the thing
that I'm like the most excited
about because I'm a musician
and that is the zero latency real
time collaboration technology
which I forgot the name of because
I just learned about it last week.
But I'll post it online.
This is really important
for musicians
who are geographically
dispersed to be able
to play together in real time.
There's this thing that happens
for musicians that's really weird,
and that -- we hear each other
and we listen to each other,
but when things are
really tight it's
because we're anticipating what
the other person is going to do.
And that's what makes an awesome,
awesome musical performance.
And so I'm extremely
excited by that.
Now you need a gig
connection for your session,
not for your library,
but for your session.
But I just go involved with that
group and I'm psyched about that
because that fulfills this promise
of actual interaction using
these wires and radio waves.
>> Alison Macrina: That's really
all they're good for [laughter].
>> Carson Block: That's
right, exactly.
Amen, sister.
Thank you very much
for your time today.
Thanks for hanging
out with us today.
Have a wonderful rest
of the conference.
[ Applause ]
>> Alison Macrina: Thanks, guys.
[ Inaudible Conversations ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.